meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen zu unserer kurzen
pressekonferenz am heutigen nachmittag
die sie wissen hat heute morgen ein
gespräch stattgefunden
auf einladung der oberbürgermeisterin zu
den vorfällen die sich der
silvesternacht hier vor unserer
hauptbahnhof und im bereich des kölner
hauptbahnhofes ereignet haben so will
nicht lange vorreden halten sondern
direkt das wort übergeben an die
verursacher vielen dank ja meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren es ist
natürlich unglaublich was hier in dieser
silvesternacht passiert ist und absolut
nicht tolerierbar und deswegen bin ich
froh dass wir heute morgen und sofort
zusammensetzen konnten mit dem
polizeipräsidenten mit dem vertreter der
bundespolizei und wir zum einen die
möglichkeit hatten dass die polizei uns
den sachverhalt erläutert hat das
bisherige ermittlungsverfahren erläutert
hat und auch über die zukünftigen
ermittlungs strukturen berichtet hat
dazu kann der pp gleich noch mal etwas
sagen wir haben heute morgen gemeinsam
maßnahmen entwickelt die dazu führen
sollen dass es solche vorfälle hier nie
wieder gibt das ist uns ganz ganz
wichtig ebenso wichtig ist aber auch
dass wir uns dass karneval feiern in
köln nicht nehmen lassen
durch solche vorfälle es wird der pp
gleich die sofortmaßnahmen so möchte ich
das einmal nennen ihnen erläutern ich
möchte ihn so viel sagen es wird
zukünftig in köln bei allen
großveranstaltungen ein
sicherheitskonzept geben das ist
vergleichbar der sicherheitskonzepte die
immer dann aufgestellt werden wenn es
auch einfach
gestalter gibt die stadt wird in diese
fiktive veranstalter rolle schlüpfen und
wird dann das klarstellen was wir
ansonsten auch von veranstaltern von
großschadensereignissen erwarten dazu
gehört der einsatz von sprachmittler
dazu gehört eine große
koordinierungsgruppe dazu gehört die
ausleuchtung von örtlichkeiten mobiler
video einsatz und viele andere dinge
auch die die veranstaltung den verlauf
der veranstaltung sicher ich würde jetzt
zunächst herren albers bitten einmal zu
den maßnahmen die sehr schnell geschehen
müssen stationieren
also vielen dank frau egger meine damen
meine herren
ich habe ja bereits auf der
pressekonferenz am gestrigen tage sie
ausführlich zu dem sachverhalt stellung
genommen
auch ich halte das für eine ereignis was
völlig unmöglich ist was in keiner weise
dollar ist sondern dass wir alles tun
müssen dass ich solch eine situation in
köln oder woanders nicht wiederholt
insofern bin ich sehr dankbar dafür
wir hatten selbst sehr früh mittelbar
nachdem leighton ist noch miteinander
telefoniert und über den sachverhalt
geschildert ihr habt ihr den sachverhalt
geschildert der auffassung werden das
ist natürlich eine polizeiliche lage ist
aber das gesamtproblem natürlich nicht
ausschließlich ein polizeiliches
problems insofern bin ich sehr dankbar
dafür dass hier auch alle aspekte
ausgeleuchtet haben die dieses thema
trophy als polizei müssen insbesondere
bei großveranstaltungen wie bei einer
großveranstaltung in anführungszeichen
ist sie sind diese vorfälle passiert
alles tun damit sich solch ein
sachverhalt wiederholt dazu werden wir
insbesondere blick auf den vor uns
liegenden karneval guckt dort besonders
auf den ball gefasst werden wir deutlich
die präsenz erhöht
der kräfte die in köln
die bürgerinnen und bürger schützen die
veranstaltung schützen werden dabei
sowohl uniformierte als auch zivile
kräfte einsetzen
wir werden darüber hinaus und das ist
sicher von der konzeption her
wir werden darüber hinaus temporär
mobile video anlagen einrichten das
heißt wir werden videobeobachtung von
nehmen insbesondere deshalb weil wir
dadurch von einem blick von oben sehr
viel besser die lage einschätzen können
und kräfte zu führen können das heißt
das besser koordinieren können darauf
werden wir uns intensiv vorbereiten
wir werden darüber hinaus prüfen
inwieweit insbesondere bei schon
häufiger aufgefallen den straftätern es
geht hierbei um personen die aus der
gruppe für taschendiebstähle in frage
kommt ob wir in den fällen sogenannte
bereichs betretungsverbote aussprechen
können das wir für einen gewissen
zeitraum einer person das betreten eines
bestimmten raumes in köln
und da sagen ich weiß sehr wohl dass die
rechtsprechung dort hohe anforderungen
stellen trotzdem werden wir auf dieses
mittel prüfen und gegebenenfalls auch
einsetzen dann würden wir dieses mittel
auch mit sogenannten melde auflagen
versehen das heißt die personen werden
aufgefordert sich in unterschiedlichen
zeiten bei der polizei bei einer
dienststelle zu melden
mir ist wichtig dass dieses in ein
gesamtkonzept der stadt eingebunden ist
insofern bin ich auch sehr dankbar dafür
dass gerade die überlegung getroffen ist
jetzt auch immer für solche großen
veranstaltungen ein sicherheitskonzept
aufzustellen da haben wir mit der stadt
köln große erfahrung was die initiierung
was die abwicklung solcher konzepte
angeht da kann man auch das gesamte
umfeld darin ein prüfen
ich habe und das ist auch in der ersten
phase passiert ich habe mit der
bundespolizei mit dem bundespolizei
präsidenten haben
völlig einigung darüber wie wir die
bundespolizei sich im bereich bahnhof
einbringt und wie wir uns im bereich der
stadt einbringen
für mich ist dieses ein wichtiger aspekt
in der gesamtbeurteilung der situation
und insbesondere in dem gesamtpaket was
wir an maßnahmen dort auflegen können
erstmal finde meine damen und herren es
wird sicherlich fragen von ihnen geben
mit blick auf die große zahl der
kollegen bitte ich darum dass
nacheinander zu machen und immer nur
eine frage zu stellen seine kette fragen
in der reihe nach oben zu arbeiten
beginnen mit der kollegen verlassen dass
ich mich ein paar worte sagen zudem der
bezeichnung dieser natur wir haben
derzeit keine erkenntnisse über täter
fest es gibt ein ermittlungsverfahren
wir haben eine ermittlungsgruppe
aufgestellt die sich mit dem
gesamtkomplex um den bahnhofsvorplatz
diesen gesamtkomplex verarbeitet dort
gibt es im moment 90 strafanzeigen die
sich auf diesen komplex beziehen
das heißt nicht dass das nicht noch mehr
werden können das wird geprüft ich gehe
auch davon aus dass noch mehr
strafanzeigen kommen ich fordere auch
alle
frauen ja insbesondere frauen auf die
belästigt worden sind die genötigt
worden sind strafanzeige bei der kölner
polizei zu erstatten ich fordere auch
alle zeugen die etwas mitbekommen haben
auf sich zu melden gegebenenfalls auch
videomaterial was diesmal von
aufgenommen haben zur verfügung zu
stellen
wir wissen derzeit wir haben bisher noch
keinen tatverdächtigen
wir wissen auch nicht wer die täter sind
das einzige was wir wissen was wir an
erkenntnis lagen haben ist zum einen
dass die kräfte also die
polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamten vor
ort wahrgenommen haben dass es sich dort
überwiegend um junge männer gehandelt
hat im alter von 18 bis 35 jahren die
aus dem nordafrikanischen raum stammen
dieses stammt überein mit den mit den
erklärungen der opfer
die beschreiben die potenziellen täter
genauso
mehr kann ich im moment zu der
potenziellen täter goufe nicht sagen
will
aber ich möchte dem noch hinzufügen dass
es absolut unzulässig ist jetzt
selbstverständlich für uns und für die
menschen die das objektiv beurteilen
mit einem mit mir die sichtbar aus
nordafrika kommt sofort die
flüchtlingsgruppe zu verbinden also das
halte ich für unzulässig und das möchte
ich auch ganz massive unterbinden es
gibt keinen hinweis dass es sich hier um
menschen handeln handelt die hier in
köln
unterkunft als flüchtlinge gezogen
anträge gestellt haben
und es gibt hinweise darauf dass die
polizei kenntnis gehabt bestimmte
gruppen die taschendiebstähle gehen raum
gegeben an tänzer trick dass die auch zu
dieser gruppe gehört haben ich kenne ich
kann dazu sagen dass personen überprüft
worden sind und die haben sich mit
derartigen papieren ausgewiesen
aber alleine dadurch dass man überprüft
worden
das heißt noch nicht dass man
tatverdächtiger ist insofern kann ich
nicht sagen dass diejenigen die
überprüft worden sind identisch mit vier
tatverdächtigen und ich bin dort sehr
vorsichtig mit der identifizierung das
ist generell das gilt nicht nur für den
silvesterabend dass es generell in köln
eine gruppe von wie sie schildern an
tänzern gibt die aber überwiegend
eigentumsdelikte taschendiebstähle
gegeben dass es richtig dass es auch
eine erkenntnis die wir schon längere
zeit haben das ist nicht neu seit
beträgt
die gibt es ok weiter geht es bei herrn
können sind ja was im polizeibericht von
neuer steht dass es in silvesterabend
sehr ruhig gewesen und sehr friedlich
wie passt das mit der letzten monaten
verlangt diese erste auskunft falsch ich
ausdrücklich sagen wir haben dort nicht
sicher die informationen zusammengeführt
als uns klar wurde dass es dort diese
schweren straftaten gehen haben wir das
sofort korrigiert das war nicht in
ordnung dass das passiert ist muss auch
klar sagen dass ist nach arbeitet worden
das war nicht richtig
ich habe das auch sofort korrigiert sage
ihnen ganz deutlich dass nicht richtig
ja wir haben schon ohnehin solche
hinweise die eben frauen oder jungen
mädchen helfen sollen sich in
situationen mit denen sie konfrontiert
werden zu bewegen sich sicherer zu
fühlen und das werden wir auch in dem
fall noch mal tun wir werden das
aktualisieren diese verhaltenshinweise
damit die frauen und junge mädchen auch
gut vorbereitet in das karneval feiern
gehen können damit sie jetzt nicht eine
sicherheitskopie unterliegen weil das
wollen wir nicht wir wollen ja auch
keine unkontrollierbaren orte in köln
wir wollen eine stadt wie sicher ist und
die lebenswert ist und in der jeder auch
feiern kann
es wird vielleicht dazu gehören das
haben wir heute morgen überlegt dass wir
unseren karneval und die zuwendung die
im karneval ja einmal erfolgt auch den
menschen aus anderen kulturkreisen
vielleicht besser erklären müssen dass
sie nicht sofort als einladung
verstanden werden können das wird auch
dazu gehören
ich bitte darum keine ketten fragen zu
stellen unsere kollegen form ist kürzer
zweier journalisten banken dieser schon
länger gibt hier ist ein bekanntes
phänomen wie viele leute haben wieder
ungefähr im augen das tut die polizei
dagegen und macht das einfach dem
stichwort nicht annimmt unter dem
stichwort organisierte kriminalität es
gibt eine extra dienststelle die sich
mit flaschen diebstahl befasst schon
seit jahren in zusammenhang in enger
zusammenarbeit mit der bundespolizei war
das auch ein thema des bahnhofs umfeld
und der bahn ist ganz konkrete zahlen
kann ich im moment nicht sagen
dollar verwaltet ich will noch mal
interessieren haben die polizisten vor
ort am bahndamm dieser nacht von den
über sollten kenntnis bekommen
also die die beamten haben von
übergriffen in der nacht kenntnis
bekommen
es hat spätestens nach der räumung des
platzes haben wir davon kenntnis
bekommen dorfen hat die polizei auch
konkret reagiert stelle könnt ihr gleich
zu sagen dass den vollen umfang der
übergriffe insbesondere der übergriffe
im bereich des sexual bereiches ist
allerdings erst am nächsten tag uns klar
geworden als wir dann auch die
strafanzeigen bekommen haben und die
opfer auch detailliert ausgesagt haben
was dort passiert ist
denn es war so dass zu einem großen teil
die sechs die über die sexuellen
übergriffe in zusammenhang standen mit
eigentumsdelikten das heißt dass dort
personen angegangen worden sind
die im september könnte jetzt mal eben
detailliert sagen was daran dass ihre
kollegen vor ort muss dass es die
funktion sexuellen übergriffen gekommen
in der tat macht ist das ja das haben
sie mitbekommen haben daraufhin auch
maßnahmen eingeleitet die hat er jetzt
gerne erläutert wir wussten was ungefähr
ab 0.45 uhr
vorher war es den einsatzkräften nicht
bekannt daraufhin hat der einsatzleiter
sofort reagiert hat die präsenz
maßnahmen im bereich des
bahnhofsvorplatzes deutlich erhöht hat
daraufhin im einsetzenden
rückreiseverkehr ende des feuerwerks
frauen angesprochen spätere frau die in
begleitung waren angesprochen auf die
gefahr aufmerksam gemacht insgesamt hat
frauen begleitet auch zu schützling
einzufangen hat sich quasi eine bustour
abgeliefert jetzt weiter bei den
kollegen von 1 konnte
können sie bestätigen dass es zu einer
vergewaltigung gekommen es ist ein
tatbestand angezeigt worden
der rechtlich eine vergewaltigung
darstellt dann immer eine möglichkeit
eine müsse distanz zu halten
die weiter als eine armlänge betrifft
also von sich aus schon gar nicht eine
große nähe zu suchen menschen die einem
fremd sind zu denen man kein gutes
vertrauensverhältnis
aber es gibt viele andere vor
möglichkeiten wir haben ich habe jetzt
leider in sich in gruppen
zusammenzufinden sich nicht trennen zu
lassen auch nicht in feierlaune zu sagen
ich gehe jetzt mal mit diesen oder jenen
mit sondern in der gruppe in der mann
losgegangen zu bleiben
also es gibt möglichkeiten die auch bei
uns bei der stadt köln dann auf der
internetseite nachzulesen sind vor allen
dingen hinweis auf andere die solche
situationen nicht wegzuschauen sondern
tatsächlich wenn sie eine solche
bedrohungslage wahrnehmen
den kontakt zur polizei zu suchen oder
andere hinzuzuholen damit diese
situation sich außer rand und band
hier kann man sich fragen warum haben
nicht viel mehr menschen die 110 gewählt
ganz einfach in dem moment als sie ihr
smartphone rausgezogen haben sie angst
haben dass es sofort weggenommen wird
also es gibt ja für diese dinge auch
eine begründung warum sich menschen dann
so verhalten dass gibt gibt generelle
präventionshinweise die auch die polizei
gibt dazu gehört dass das eben
geschildert wird worden ist von vdk es
geht aber auch
fremde konkret anzusprechen und um hilfe
zu bitten auch ganz konkret sie da mit
einem grünen hut helfen sie mama bitte
vielleicht noch von denen zu denen eben
von verräter angesprochene notrufes hat
auf der leitstelle in der nacht drei
konkrete notrufe zu dem sachverhalt
gegeben die dann auch zu einsätzen
geführt hat sonst geht es weiter bei der
kollegen hier vorne und dann gehen wir
nach davon
ich habe sie alle erklären wo das
herkommt also dieses große sich bilden
also erstens es gibt im moment noch nach
meiner kenntnis keine verbindung zu dem
sonntag
die ermittlungen sind auch deshalb nicht
ganz einfach weil die opfer und das
verstehe ich auch die opfer keine
tatverdächtigen identifizieren können
wir haben opfer gefragt ob sie personen
wiedererkennen können
sie haben das in aller regel verneint
das macht die arbeit nicht einfacher
deshalb werten wir jetzt videomaterial
aus deshalb auch meine bitte an die
öffentlichkeit uns material zur
verfügung zu stellen um dann
sachverhalte zusammenzuführen um dann
auch menschen
tatverdächtige einer tat zu überführen
das wird nicht ganz einfach und nicht
ganz einfache dinge dauern auch einfach
da geht gründlichkeit vor schnelligkeit
so der kommentar der dritte band aber
noch eine frage kann ich im moment
spekulieren möchte ich aber nicht
wir haben uns intensiv um den bares
vorplatz und wer sich in köln auf
auskennen um den weltjugendtags wie ich
gerade im vergangenen jahr gekümmert
nach unseren erkenntnissen ist die
tätergruppe die dort btm delikte begeht
nicht die tätergruppe die offensichtlich
aufgetreten ist wir waren an dem abend
ordentlich aufgestellt wir haben die
kräfte gehabt die wir brauchten das
können sie schon daran sehen dass wir
eben zum jahreswende den kompletten
platz geräumt haben als es dort zu
störungen gekommen ist dass dort zu
pyrotechnik einsatz gekommen ist
da hatten wir ausreichend kräfte dieses
phänomen das will ich nicht verhehlen
was ja auch in anderen städten
aufgetreten ist
in anderer form war sich erneut
es gibt auch übrig dass die polizei
ursprünglich gerufen worden sei weil ich
das mal zwei gruppen miteinander im
streit
der einsatz begann damit dass sich auf
dem bahnhofsvorplatz und auf der treppe
ungefähr tausende gut 1000 von mir eben
geschilderten menschen männer aufhielten
die mit pyrotechnik entweder in der
gruppe die pyrotechnik gezündet haben
beziehungsweise von oben auf passanten
die unten war geschossen hat daraufhin
hat der zuständigen polizeiführer
entschieden dass dieser rollen platz
komplett geräumt wird und das ist dann
auch verfolgt das sind nicht parallel
laufende sondern nacheinander
verlaufende scharf an weil der zweite
sachverhalt die nicht geschildert dass
danach gelaufen ist nach unserer
erkenntnis waren offensichtlich person
aus der ersten gruppe auch in der
zweiten gruppe vertreten ja wohl die
kollegin
das kann ich schwer sagen das müssen ja
mittel zu bringen wann der erste
übergriff war ich würde die situation
aber nicht rechtlos nennen sondern
polizei war präsent es ging darum das
wahrzunehmen nur sie müssen sich das
vorstellen das war ein dieser bonus
vorplatz wenn sie ihn kennen es ein
großer platz
und wenn ein großveranstaltung in köln
ist dann strömen danach tausende von
menschen in den bahnhof das heißt dass
nach voll von menschen und in diesem
getümmel ist es zu diesen ereignissen
gekommen und der thema theben schon
geschildert welche maßnahmen die polizei
eingeleitet hat um diese straftaten zu
verlangen dass das nicht gelungen ist
habe ich geschildert aber offensichtlich
ist das ja dann auch daran dass nicht
die richtigen instrumente bisher auf
dieses wir nennen es mal vorsichtig
phänomen weil ich das sehr verharmlosen
diesen ausdruck aber um das rechtzeitig
zu erkennen und zu unterbinden und das
muss ja unser ziel sein dass wir solche
zusammenrottung davon gruppen von
männern die frauen spießruten laufen
lassen nicht mehr zugelassen haben das
wird deshalb auch die jetzigen maßnahmen
durch videografiert auch von oben her
besser zu erkennen was passiert auf dem
platz ja jetzt die kollegen hier strenge
gegenüber wenn sie personen der tat
überführen werden sie der justiz über
eignet und die justiz wird ein urteil
fällen was danach mit ihnen passieren
kann ich nicht sagen das hängt von
ausländerrechtlichen bedingungen ab aber
ich will nicht verhehlen ich halte es
für notwendig dass menschen die ihre
schwere straftaten begehen dann auch die
bundesrepublik verlassen müssen
ich weiß sehr wohl dass das
ausgesprochen schwierig ist weil sie
keine papiere keine papiere haben aber
ich kann ihnen auch sagen dass die
polizei alles tun wird um das zu
unterstützen aber das ist kein leichter
weg
ich halte das allerdings für
erforderlich nicht nur aus den
erkenntnissen die wir von silvester
haben sondern wir haben natürlich auch
eine tätergruppe hier in köln aber in
ganz nordrhein westfalen wie immer
wieder straftaten begeht und der die wir
auch immer wieder über führung und wo es
auch richtig vorteile wohl weiter geht's
mit den stau 1000 personen
gibt es inzwischen erkenntnisse auch die
sich in irgendeiner form zu essen folge
für zur zweiten frage nahe und herr
stina wir noch keine erkenntnisse dazu
das müssen die ermittlungen versuchen
aufzuhellen zur ersten frage kann ich
sagen dass durch die einsatzkräfte im
bereich bahnhofsvorplatz domplatte so
ganz grob wie mal daumen etwa 100
personen bezogene maßnahmen getroffen
worden sind davon im wasser die
feststellung von identitäten sind auch
einige in gewahrsam nahmen erfolg einige
festen haben aber die ganz überwiegende
anzahl war die feststellung von
identitäten so ich geh jetzt hier vorne
in die ecke der kollege in jackett sagen
spiegel vermeintlich noch mal ein
bisschen verwirrung gibt es
chronologisch und ganz dezidiert sagen
dann passierte was und sportwagen waren
passierte kraft in waren und welche
behörde als bundespolizei oder
chronologisch zum ablauf vielleicht
zunächst die anderen fragen werden dann
danach es ist so dass wir bereits gegen
21 uhr auf dem bahnhofsvorplatz und an
den treppen zum dom eine gruppe von
zunächst 400 bis 500 personen
festgestellt haben
ganz überwiegend oder ausschließlich
junge männer von 18 bis 35
zu diesem zeitpunkt wurde reichlich
alkohol vor ort konsumiert es wurde
unkontrolliert feuerwerkskörper
abgebrannt sowohl in der menge als auch
später von der domplatte oben in die
untenstehende personengruppe gegen 23
uhr hatte sich diese gruppe auf circa
1000 personen vergrößert zusammensetzung
licht der ersten gruppe also überwiegend
in beziehungsweise ausschließlich junge
männer das abfeuern von
feuerwerkskörpern nahezu es kam zu
konkreten gefährdungssituationen die
stimmung in der gruppe wurde auch
aggressiver unkontrollierter die
personen wurden von den einsatzkräften
als völlig enthemmt und auch weitgehend
unbeeindruckt
polizeilichen maßnahmen geschildert
daraufhin erfolgte dann der entschluss
den bahnhofsvorplatz und die dom treppe
sukzessiv zu räumen weil man befürchtete
dass nach ende oder mit einsetzen des
feuerwerks und 0 uhr es dort zu einer
eskalation der lage kommen würde diese
räumung war schwierig sie hat den
einsatzkräften vieles abverlangt sie ist
dennoch reibungsfrei gelungen und die
lage hat sich zunächst beruhigt der
zugang zur lohn treppe wurde dann
gesperrt diese stern wurde bis 0.45
aufrechterhalten
die vorher 1000 auf der platte in einer
gesamten gruppe befindlichen personen
hatten sich um kleinere gruppierungen in
die umgebung zerstreut
erst zu diesem zeitpunkt also gegen 1
uhr bekamen unsere einsatzkräfte vor ort
die ersten hinweise darauf dass es zu
übergriffen gekommen war
die sich nicht nur im bereich des
üblichen taschendiebstahls bewegten
sondern eben auch scheinbar massiv aber
noch nicht in ihrem ausmaß völlig fn hat
mit sexuellen übergriffen auf frauen
verbunden gewesen waren
daraufhin hat der einsatzleiter reagiert
hat alle kräfte die für den silvester
einsatz zur verfügung standen
im bereich des hauptbahnhofs des
planungs vorplatzes außerhalb des
gebäudes konzentriert es hatte vorher
schon mit der bundespolizei absprachen
über die übergabe verfahren an der
bahnhof für und über die
verfahrensweisen gegeben und wir haben
dann die eben schon geschildert begonnen
frauen anzusprechen zu begleiten zu
schützen
zu der frage helfen räumlichkeiten
zuständigkeiten die zuständigkeit grenze
für diesen einsatz war verabredet ist
vergröbert gesagt die bahnhofs tür
das heißt alles was außerhalb des
bahnhofs stattfand war in der
verantwortung der polizei in köln
und alles was innerhalb des wahns
stattfand in der verantwortung die
bundespolizei aber noch ein dritter teil
und es damit bald was die bude
polizei gemacht wenn sie uns an dieser
stelle nicht kommentieren
niederrad die haben vergleichbare
maßnahmen getroffen die unsere ergänzt
haben wir haben sehr gut
zusammengearbeitet was die bundespolizei
polizei gemacht hatte entschied sich mal
erstellt wurde sap möchte ich noch nicht
sagt fraktion weiter seine bahnhof
reingegangen sind auch selber den
bahnhof reingegangen sind nämlich eine
tür stehen geblieben sind
die stadtpolizei ist auch den bahnhof
fertig das kann ich ihnen nicht in jedem
einzelfall sagen von pro jahr haben wir
die frauen bis zur tür begleiten und im
bahnhof selbst war die bundespolizei ich
bitte nochmals darum disziplin ja ein
zweites können die kollegen wirklich
nicht zum zuge kommen jetzt ist der
kollege im diese räumung die sie gerade
schildern hatte dazu geführt dass sich
die täter möglich
nein die übergriffe waren ja vorher
schon zu großen teilen erfolgt sie sind
leider mit der räume nicht beendet
gewesen
das muss man feststellen so jetzt die
kollegin hinten in der ecke
es ist wenn man dopt es gibt keine 1000
meter es gibt eine gruppe von 1000
menschen aus der heraus nachher ist die
gruppe deutlich kleiner gewesen aus der
heraus straftaten begangen worden sind
es gibt keine 1000 täter und die polizei
das wird das ergebnis des
ermittlungsverfahrens soll
wir müssen jetzt sehen wie viel ich habe
90 strafanzeigen wie sich auf taten
beziehen
das heißt aber nicht dass es 90
straftäter gibt es kann gut sein dass
einzelne dass einzelne opfer mehrere
opfer opfer eines straftäters geworden
sind es kann auch sein dass ein
straftäter ein ein opfer opfer von
mehreren straftätern geworden ist
deshalb kann ich eine zahl von tätern
oder tatverdächtigen moment in keiner
weise bestätigen das muss das
ermittlungsergebnis bringen
genau die sind das die werden wir
einsetzen
selbst dann welche besorgungen wie viel
wir brauchen wenn wir die und werden
gegebenenfalls auch aus anderen
kreispolizeibehörden diese fahrzeuge
antwort
so jetzt herr bischof und dann gehen wir
noch mal ableitung und die polizei den
bahnhofsvorplatz beobachtet von unten
oder von oben an der treppe sowohl als
auch
also in so einer situation muss ich ihm
sagen brauche ich keinen druck mehr von
irgendwem also wenn in dieser stadt wie
auch in anderen städten wie wir jetzt
wissen solche dinge geschehen dann ist
das grund genug alles zu tun um eine
wiederholung zu vermeiden und dafür
gehört dazu gehört für mich eben gerade
bei großveranstaltungen auch mehr
präsenz weil ich der absoluten
überzeugung bin dass uniformierte
präsident präsenz auch dazu führt dass
menschen sich einfach anders benehmen
aber nochmal deutlich machen als wir
erkannt haben und das war am ersten im
laufe des ersten erkannt haben dass es
diese straftaten gibt es sofort eine
ermittlungsgruppe zusammengestellt
worden die sich dem thema annimmt da war
von politik von bundespolitischen
äußerungen klicks die rede
dazu dürfte es auch überhaupt gar nicht
wenn die da wohl maßnahmen treffen
und sind diese aufrufe natürlich auch
bekannte wir sehen sie natürlich mit
großer sorge wobei es auch nicht
wirklich verwunderlich ist dass die
aufrufe kommen wir sind dergestalt
darauf vorbereitet dass wir ab dem
heutigen tag gezielte einsatzmaßnahmen
meine mutmaßlichen treff unten treffen
werden wir werden auch dort eine starke
präsenz zeigen und es wird das darf ich
sagen eine niedrige 1 schweiz werde
geben dann geht es weiter mit der
kollegin erscheint man es ja lustig
fahrer zwei fragen zum einen es gab es
ja schon längeres phänomen mit dem
anfangs taschendiebstählen inwieweit
sagen haben sie früher richtig reagiert
hätte man das verhindern können weil und
dann frage ich mich wie sie jederzeit
präsenz zeigen wollen mit einem sehr
geringen personalstand zum ersten es gab
es bisher immer das form des antanzen
davon waren allerdings überwiegend
männer betroffen und spielte sich in
aller regel nicht offen im sexuellen
bereich
münchen getroffen haben in der form
haben sie sich in der regel auf den
ringen betroffen dieses phänomen haben
wir bisher auf dem ring ab das war auch
nicht so massiv dass dort große gruppen
aufgetreten sind sondern die sind eher
in einzelgruppen aufgetreten und auch
nicht in dieser hohen anzahl das habe
ich ihnen schon geschildert es gibt
einen in köln eine dienststelle
die sich und das ist glaube ich einmalig
in deutschland die sich mit tasten
diebstahl beschäftigt und genau mit
diesem phänomen in zusammenarbeit mit
der bundespolizei
und dort gibt es ausgesprochen gute
ermittlungsergebnis werden die haben
viele täter festnahm und kommen auch zur
verurteilung den rest habe ich eben
schon erzählt und erläutert und es wir
haben da nur ein links es gibt es gibt
ein konzept opa wie eine
ordnungspartnerschaft dinge die wir mit
der stadt gemeinsam machen wo wir an
jedem wochenende im sommer mehr im
winter nicht allzu viel bis zu 60 60
kräfte einsetzen auf eine strecke von
800 meter ungefähr um dort deutlich mit
präsenz von polizei da zu sein und dort
auch deutlich zu machen dass diese
straftaten nicht geduldet werden und das
ist mit dem personal das im kölner
machbar
das kann das nicht machen darüber noch
lernen auch immer wieder kräfte
zusätzliche 100 schaffte es wird auch
jetzt seien von anderen
kreispolizeibehörden abgeordnet
kollege einmal fragen was personal waren
im einsatz sagte ausschließlich für den
silvester einsatz knapp 150 und dann
darüber hinaus natürlich noch den
normalstreifen die ist der deutlich
verstärkt
das heißt für karneval ist aber mit
einer erhöhung dieser wir haben den
silvester einsatz vor dem hintergrund
der bisherige silvester nicht geplant
gehabt kräfteansatz war in diesem jahr
ist karneval in einer ganz anderen
größenordnung für verwaiste und anna
klose auch gerne noch mal nachfragen
sagen wir erhöhen die polizei präsenz
insbesondere der weiberfastnacht
gegangen und meinen sie die
polizeipräsenz im vergleich zu
bisherigen weiberfastnacht in köln und
könnte das vielleicht noch mal so ein
bisschen die dimension berufung zu
beschreiben wenn
wir haben uns bewusst heute zusammen
gesetzt und haben auch abgestimmt dass
wir ein gesamtkonzept in der stadt
machen auch mit der stadt auch die stadt
will ihre kräfte erhöhen das ist auch
richtig so dass wir insgesamt zu einer
anderen reaktion auch auf solche
phänomene kommen um in dem rahmen wird
es natürlich auch eine erhöhung der
polizeilichen kräften geben
ich glaube nicht dass alles um menschen
die über richtig dimensioniert kann ich
heute deshalb man es sagen weil wir erst
natürlich gucken müssen welche
erfahrungen durch anforderungen nicht
aus den zurückliegenden ereignissen
wirklich ernähren würden und daraufhin
wie die partie eingeplant werden sie
wird wieder sein das ganze werden wie
viel kann vorkommen dass eine frage
jetzt jetzt mehr auf temporäre
videoüberwacht
wir sind nicht so richtig klar wie das
altweiberfastnacht oder rosenmontag
funktionieren
videoüberwachung die ins ziel
das erste ziel ist von möglichst
erhöhter position in eine menschenmenge
angucken zu können
das dient nicht primär der
beweissicherung weil wir vielleicht noch
gar keine straftat haben sondern dass
ihnen den frühzeitigen erkennen
gefährliche entwicklung in der
menschenmenge und wenn die polizei
ebenerdig aufstellen sehen sich vor die
köpfe und die rücken der menschen
deswegen ist das erste ziel mit dieser
videoüberwachung in die regierung hinein
zu gucken
von einem erhöhten standpunkt deswegen
von der massen aus das kann auch hier
und da aus einem objekt man denkt man
nennt das auch mal bademeister position
und dass das zweite meister position
das zweite ist natürlich kostümierung in
fußballvereinen
das zweite ist natürlich der versuch an
möglichst viele erkenntnisse
heranzukommen
auch wenn die direkte identifizierung
nicht möglich ist das kann auch bedeuten
dass eine person kostümiert die an einer
straftat beteiligt war über die
videokamera verfolgt wird und anderen
kräften zugesprochen wird zum beispiel
hat also auch sowas wird seinem klub
damit kann man sagt diese diese
maßnahmen sind alleine gefahren ab
während sie stützen sich auf
polizeirecht und nicht oft
der kollege hier
gewisse anzahl der kameras kann ich
nichts zu sagen wir sammeln moment alle
daten ein die wir kriegen können kann
ich nicht zu sagen welche kameras der
moment aktiv sein kann ich nichts um
eine ausbildung ich kann im moment gar
nichts zu sagen weil ich nicht dass ich
weiß dass die ermittlungsgruppe derzeit
video material gesammelt und ein wort
welches segment schon hat und inwieweit
es auswertbar ist und was da auch für
daten drauf da kann ich ihnen mit
lichtzeichen weiter geht es mit dem
bischof radl meister reputation haben
gerade gesagt dass sie auf
beobachtungsposten hatten oben auf der
domplatte
das ist eine position diesem fall ohne
kammer aber mit
also noch einmal die frage warum haben
ihre banken nichts von den vorfällen
unter teenagern mit gesehen wenn man den
blick auf eine menschen hingerichtet
zumal bei dunkelheit dann ist es endlich
so doch ist dieser plötzlich dennoch es
ist ein unterschied ob wir das um offen
über 23 uhr reden zu dieser jahreszeit
oder ob wir über die jetzige tageszeit
reden wenn sie in einer menschengruppe
von 1000 personen punktuell an einem
ruhm ein strafbares dann müssen sie ganz
ganz ganz viel glück haben dass sie das
erkennen können
das ist in menschenmassen enorm
schwierig diese erfahrung haben wir ja
nicht nur bei solchen veranstaltungen
wir haben sie bei fußballspielen
wir haben sie bei demonstrationen zum
beispiel auch es ist enorm schwierig
selbst wenn sie von oben drücken weil
zum beispiel die beobachtungs kraft
nicht das kann was eine kamera kann die
kamera kann hineinzoomen
wenn man den verdacht es kommt da ist
etwas das können sie verwoben und bei
dunkelheit mit
soweit die pressekonferenz der kölner
polizei und der kölner
oberbürgermeisterin henriette reker